EMILY PUTZE: As
many of you know,
hopefully, digital
wellness is a big priority
for Google this year.
And because
technology is becoming
a bigger and bigger part
of everyone's lives,
what we often hear from
users today, though,
is that they want to
find a better way--
to find a better balance
with the technology
that they use and love
every day, especially
with their phones.
So as Play and Android, from a
platform and operating system
perspective, we
obviously believe
that it's our responsibility
to build products
for users that make their
lives easier and better
and not detract from them.
As you can imagine, on the
games team, over the past year,
we've been thinking a lot about
these trends and core values
at large, especially
in relation to how
they translate to our work with
game developers in the game
space.
And what's interesting
about the game space,
and why I wanted to start
off this panel talking
about wellness, is that
often, when it comes to games,
the idea of mindfulness
and sustainability
can sometimes be at odds.
Now I want to be clear.
When I talk about
mindfulness, I mean
mindfulness in terms of more
meaningful user engagement.
And they can often feel at odds.
We're all going
after people's time,
their money, user mindshare.
But how do you pursue
deep engagement
without necessarily
causing burnout?
And how do you pursue more
meaningful monetization
without necessarily
causing buyer's remorse?
And how do you do
both of these things
well while also achieving
your business objectives?
Obviously, that balance is a
really difficult one to strike.
But when I personally
think about a developer who
has proven that bottom lines and
mindfulness don't necessarily
have to be at odds, who
actually intentionally uses
more meaningful engagement
and more sustainable
monetization as a
strategy to achieve
their impressive business
goals, I think of Crowdstar.
So I am very excited to
have a group of people here
from Crowdstar today who
are going to join me up
on stage in a second to
tell us a little bit more
about their approach to gaming
in general, what makes them
different, and how they believe
these differences have played
into their success in the
market in recent years
and helped them build very
healthy and sustainable
businesses.
OK, let's welcome
them up to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, it's very bright.
CHRIS MCGILL: Very bright.
EMILY PUTZE: OK, well, let's
first do some introductions.
Chris.
CHRIS MCGILL: Hi,
I'm Chris McGill.
I'm the general manager
of "Design Home."
SARAH FUCHS: I'm Sarah Fuchs.
I'm the general manager
of "Covet Fashion."
EMILY PUTZE: Thank you
guys for joining us.
CHRIS MCGILL: It's a pleasure.
EMILY PUTZE: Great,
let's kick it off.
So creative fashion and
interior design games--
Chris, will you tell us a little
bit about how you and your team
approached creating these
games in this space?
CHRIS MCGILL: I think
the crib notes are really
about Crowdstar. so Crowdstar,
just quickly, has been
several different companies.
And in a moment of
desperation, when
Facebook changed
policies, when they
were going to run out of
money, sometimes that moment
of desperation,
about six years ago,
unleashes you from the rules.
And it was prior to me.
But "Covet Fashion" came about
when they had no time left,
and they decided to take just
a radical different approach,
because there was no downside.
And what they did is, instead
of a fail fast game environment,
they actually looked
for the white space,
tried to figure out
who is not served,
and took this crazy chance
of not only creating
an entertaining game, but one
that could have intrinsic value
in your life outside the game.
And that's-- you know, "Design
Home" iterated on that.
And it's its own entity.
But it's the same principle
of entertaining people with--
about the things that
they love, but also
having a connection
to what you do,
and how you do it,
and make your life
more informed
outside of the game.
It's really an app
and a game in one.
EMILY PUTZE: And it worked.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yeah.
So five years later--
I mean, Sarah can tell you--
I mean, "Covet Fashion"
is having its record year,
you know?
And "Home" is a
top-30-grossing app.
EMILY PUTZE: Awesome.
Well obviously,
Crowdstar has carved out
this very interesting
space for itself
to work in in terms of its
innovative and atypical game
design.
But what is it that you
think makes these games so
unique and successful?
Sarah?
SARAH FUCHS: I think we meet
the players where they are.
I think we have thought
about what women like to do
and found a way to make that
fun, and make that a game,
and make that interesting.
And we spend a lot of time
learning about our players.
And I think the more when
we get to know our players,
and the more we think
about what emotion
we want our players to
have when they're playing,
and when they're done playing,
and when they make a purchase,
we really think
about the experience
that's valuable for them.
And we want them to come away
with this positive feeling.
And so we use that as
kind of a North Star
for how we design our games.
EMILY PUTZE: So its a strong
player-first kind of mentality.
SARAH FUCHS: Player-first, 100%.
EMILY PUTZE: Another thing
that's really interesting about
Crowdstar, I think, in
terms of a game-- or sorry,
about "Covet" and "Design
Home," in terms of games--
is this intrinsic reward
aspect of your games.
Will you expand upon
that a little bit?
SARAH FUCHS: Sure, I mean,
we want players to play--
we don't necessarily use kind of
tried and true game mechanics.
We are event-based.
And so we provide five
to six events every day.
And players come in, and they
have a-- well, "Covet Fashion,"
they have a model
that they dress.
And then they get voted on.
And they get to enjoy
the rewards from that.
So we don't have, necessarily,
extrinsic rewards for them.
They come back, and they are
passionate about what they do.
EMILY PUTZE: And one thing
that has stuck with me in some
of our conversations is that
your players are actually
happier when they're
done playing "Covet"
or playing "Design Home."
That's pretty
unusual, I would say.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yeah,
there's actually
a study that shows,
a year later,
in "Covet Fashion," that women
are happier, because it's a--
you don't put yourself
into the game.
It's not about you, or
your body, or your face.
You actually get to learn what
you like, what you don't like.
And a year later, when you
step out of your house,
whether you're going on
a date, a job interview,
or out with your
girlfriends, you
feel a little more
confident about yourself.
So we try to be additive
to our players' lives.
SARAH FUCHS: And we try
to measure that too.
I mean, you can't
measure happiness.
That's impossible.
If we could do that, that
would be like the secret sauce.
But we do try to
engage with our players
as often as we possibly
can to understand
what makes them happy.
We send random surveys--
how did you like this challenge?
We poll them at random times.
We have a style council
on "Covet Fashion"
that has 25,000 players that
we talk to on a regular basis.
We make videos for them.
We give them feedback.
We give them exclusive access.
And we really want to
take what our players have
to say and make sure that
we're delivering the experience
that's right for them.
CHRIS MCGILL: Right, It's a
balance of heave, heavy quant,
but also tied in
with a lot of qual.
EMILY PUTZE: So obviously, this
user-centric kind of strategy
is something that you've
stayed very tied to.
I think you've said these
businesses kind of grew out
of seizing the white
space that was available.
But you've clearly stayed
very tied to your players.
How much has that continued
to drive the growth
and evolution of these games?
CHRIS MCGILL: I think
it's everything.
EMILY PUTZE: Good.
CHRIS MCGILL: I mean, it's the
reason why we get out of bed.
I mean, we have to have a
love affair with our users.
Like, we have to understand
them quantitatively in the game.
We have to understand them
qualitatively in the game,
but also in their lives.
And the idea is-- we actually
write down the emotions
that we want you to
feel when you play
the game, but also the emotions
you want to feel when you close
the game so that you're not
just entertained, but just
then find, an hour
later, you close the app
and you're another hour older.
SARAH FUCHS: Exactly right.
I love it.
EMILY PUTZE: OK, so
using user sentiment
to guide game design
obviously makes sense.
But as you mentioned,
Sarah, it's really tricky.
SARAH FUCHS: Yeah.
EMILY PUTZE: How
do you guys balance
between optimizing
for user sentiment
against optimizing for key
business KPIs like engagement
or revenue?
CHRIS MCGILL: You do this one.
SARAH FUCHS: OK.
So obviously, we're
thinking about KPIs.
But when we're
designing a new feature,
we'll make sure we stop and
think, is this a retention KPI?
Is this a retention feature?
Is this an engagement feature?
Is this a revenue feature?
And we really think about that.
And often, we are in
the midst of designing
this fantastic engagement
feature that's coming soon,
but as we're designing,
we think, oh my gosh,
we could totally monetize
the crap out of this.
And we could totally
make money here.
And then we're
like, you guys, no,
that's not what this is about.
We want to engage our players.
It's about the long game for us.
It's not about
that instant buck.
Like, we could have
a sale tomorrow
and have a million-dollar day.
But the hangover for that
would be so just not worth it.
So we really think about the
long game for our players
and get-- and breath--
as many players as we possibly
can paying a little bit,
but enjoying their time.
CHRIS MCGILL: And that is how
to maximize revenue for us.
I mean, that is it.
It's not like, oh,
altruism, you know?
SARAH FUCHS: We're
still about the revenue.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yeah,
it's a business,
But it's a question of, we're
trying to build a platform,
a long-standing platform
that never wears out.
And so it's a matter of what
you do and when you do it.
And these are--
I mean, we have these fights all
the time, though, internally.
EMILY PUTZE: What fights?
SARAH FUCHS: Oh, we
have knock-down--
EMILY PUTZE: Tell
us about the fights.
SARAH FUCHS: --knock-down,
drag-out fights.
CHRIS MCGILL: Not me, Sarah.
SARAH FUCHS: Oh, no.
I'd win.
EMILY PUTZE: No, but
seriously, what are these--
I'm assuming the
debate's about--
CHRIS MCGILL: It's really
what we're talking about.
It's like, OK, well, we
could put in this feature.
And we know we leave
money on the table--
short-term money-- every
day in the interest
of long-term money.
And that's the balance that
we have to argue about,
in a healthy way, every day.
We're like, OK, we
know, this month, we
can make an extra $2 million.
But that's going to lead
to retention issues.
And that's actually not
going to enrich their lives.
And we also make sure--
I mean, the stat that
I'm most proud of
is actually the percentage
of our payer base.
So every day, we have a
million women in the game.
And at any given point, 40% of
them have been a payer, right?
So it's about having a
broad and engaged audience
that doesn't pay a ton.
We're like the anti-whale
hunters, right?
SARAH FUCHS: And we don't
like the term "whale."
CHRIS MCGILL: No.
SARAH FUCHS: We don't
use the term "whale"
except to say we don't
use the term "whale."
CHRIS MCGILL: Right.
I'm sorry I said "whale."
SARAH FUCHS: Thank you.
EMILY PUTZE: So it sounds
like, from a monetization
perspective--
I want to dive into the
engagement perspective
piece in a second, about
something that Chris just said.
But from a monetization
perspective,
it sounds like your North
Star is getting users
to pay small amounts over time.
So there's a consistency
aspect with that.
So more is not necessarily
better is what I'm hearing.
SARAH FUCHS: Correct, I think--
sorry, I'll take this,
and you can jump in.
Chris, you often
say we can't make
our payers play more than--
pay more than $10 a day.
It's really hard to do that.
And for us it's
about more people
engaging than one
person paying $100,000.
EMILY PUTZE: Right.
CHRIS MCGILL: It's
that combined with we
actually make sure that
they'll play too long.
We published-- well, "Covet,"
six, "Home," five live ops
challenges a day
that take, typically,
10 minutes to complete.
And we space them out
throughout the day.
So you can't even--
if you play them all, you can't
play more than one at a time.
And then we actually
tell you to go away.
Get back to your life.
There will be another
challenge, you know?
EMILY PUTZE: In some way,
you're capping engagement.
SARAH FUCHS: We
want to leave them
with more, that
feeling of, oh, I
want to do more, rather
than, oh, I'm bored,
I'm going to stop
for-- or I'm bored--
or I have to stop because
of something else.
We want them to want to
come back, and be excited
for their challenge results, and
be excited for the next thing.
We have a great relationship
with our community on "Covet."
And I have players
who've told me
they have timers for when they
know the next event is going
to start.
EMILY PUTZE: Right.
SARAH FUCHS: And
I'm like, oh, OK.
I love that.
That's great.
But there's that
feeling of wanting more.
EMILY PUTZE: Yep.
And I know you guys
said a lot of this
is a little bit--
are a little bit
science in terms of
constantly balancing
the qual and the quant.
Have you ever experimented
on doing more challenges?
And if so, what happened?
EMILY PUTZE: Yes,
and we still do.
I mean, sometimes we'll run a
bonus challenge and stuff still
today.
But also, when "Covet" was
being iterated on, they--
and it's actually
before my time--
they iterated on
many, many challenges,
like eight, nine, 10 a day.
And they settled on six.
And that was some
science and some art,
because they didn't have
the long-term retention
data at that point.
But it's just what felt right
to them in play testing.
And it was a little-- also
a little bit of an accident.
Because they also would run
out these 10 and realize,
holy crap, we don't
have enough people
to make more at that time.
I mean, we do now.
And it just is a nice rhythm.
And they also space them out
so that it's like a snack
throughout your day.
It's relevant to you no matter
where you live in the globe.
There's something
happening when you get up.
And we talk about it.
Like, we could run out many,
many, many more challenges
per day now, but
we don't want to.
And this is just-- you know,
it's a little-- it's atypical
game design.
It's not for everybody.
But this is what's
working for us.
EMILY PUTZE: Right, makes sense.
So would it be fair to
say that, in general, you
optimize these
games for the masses
versus your top 20% of players?
CHRIS MCGILL: Absolutely--
SARAH FUCHS: 100%
CHRIS MCGILL: --without a doubt.
Like, we want a broad, broad
player base and payer base.
Because if you take out--
if you delight a user to the
point where they want to take
out $2, %5, they're more
invested in the game.
You've proven something to them.
But we don't get up
to take out thousands
of dollars out of if you--
it it's about a broad,
invested player base.
EMILY PUTZE: And
so in that sense.
SARAH FUCHS: Yeah, I
was just going to say,
I can give you an
example of that.
So in "Covet Fashion," we
have these hair accessories
that everybody wants.
And from time to time,
we do these $4.99 hair
accessory sales.
And we did one $0.99 one.
And we found that we made
more money with the $4.99 one,
but more players bought
with a $0.99 one.
So we're sticking
with the $0.99 one.
Because we want more players
to convert, and engage, and buy
more things later.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yeah,
what we know is
that's actually monetizing
revenue over the long run,
right?
Because those people have
known invested $0.99,
they're more invested
in the platform.
The hair accessories did
not work for me, by the way.
So that's just, like,
the way we roll.
EMILY PUTZE: Totally.
Let's get some of those
for him in "Covet."
SARAH FUCHS: Oh,
yes, definitely.
The bald is beautiful.
CHRIS MCGILL: You know,
we did have a bald--
SARAH FUCHS: We do, yeah.
EMILY PUTZE: So Sarah,
something that you just said
is interesting.
When you are thinking about
making product decisions--
so the scenario you just
described with the $4.99 versus
$0.99, it sounds like you
guys would even make changes
in the game if it was
revenue-neutral, let's say,
if it increased your payer--
if the payer footprint--
SARAH FUCHS: We do.
And you know, that's not--
I come from a more
traditional gaming background.
It was a bit of a mind
shift for me switching.
But there are-- we
do have arguments.
We have debates.
We say, you know, but we
could make all of this money.
But then we also
think, but hey, we
could keep-- we could get all
these players who will then
make more money for
us in the long run.
So it is about revenue.
It's just about being mindful
that we don't need to make--
to have a million-dollar day.
We'd rather have many players
play so that we can make more
in the end.
CHRIS MCGILL: Right, so you can
have a $50-plus-million-dollar
year.
EMILY PUTZE: Exactly.
CHRIS MCGILL: Right.
EMILY PUTZE: Right
SARAH FUCHS: Exactly.
EMILY PUTZE: So how do you think
about retaining-- we've just
said, when users play
into the game, that
means they're probably
more invested in the game,
they spend more time in
it So you're actually,
from a monetization
perspective, still optimizing
for what-- it sounds like
long-term engagement.
But how do you think
about retaining users
in the game that don't
want to spend dollars?
SARAH FUCHS: So we have a lot of
different ways that payers who
don't--
so sorry, that players
who don't pay can advance.
We have rewarding video ads.
We have offer walls.
But in "Covet," we
also have gifting.
We have these runway
rallies where you
play within your fashion house.
And there are a lot of different
ways to progress faster.
You don't have to pay.
And in fact, we have a large
percentage that don't pay,
and still enjoy, and still
have advanced to level 66,
and are very happy.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yeah,
"Home's" the same way.
And we have a borrowing capacity
if you bring a friend in,
the same tools.
And we have a daily gift.
You just can't play
either as much,
or maybe do as high-quality
a design as you might like.
You really have to
make that decision.
EMILY PUTZE: Yeah, and it sounds
like one of the advantages
that you guys have
is that, because you
have such a broad payer
base, you don't actually
feel the pressure to
design the game in a way
that it's more focused towards
the top 20% of your users.
You actually can
keep it very open.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yes,
and on top of that,
if you actually look
at this audience,
and it's an older
female audience,
it's also a different approach.
It's not a zero-sum game.
It's a positive-sum game.
And it's not about
creating a competition
where there's stress.
And these games are
about creativity,
and relaxation, and inspiration.
I mean, people
call it Pinterest--
The Game, you know?
SARAH FUCHS: But we
do think about that.
I mean, back in January,
"Covet" ran an experiment
where we loosened
our restrictions,
the things that you had to
do to enter a challenge.
And we're like-- everybody's
like, oh no, we're
going to not make
money-- panic attack.
But "Design Home"
was doing so well,
we had a little bit
of a cushion to be
able to try these experiments.
And we loosened
our restrictions,
and engagement went up.
Revenue stayed the same.
So that engagement piece, I
can't emphasize it enough.
And there's fear associated
with not doing these things.
And it's fortunate that we did
have the "Design Home" cushion.
Thank you, Chris.
But we were able to
run these experiments.
And we were able to really
see that engagement matters.
EMILY PUTZE: How do you guys
manage against short-term
pressure internally
to think about--
I'm sorry, pressure internally--
to think about short-term KPIs
and not prioritize those over
this ideal long-term state.
SARAH FUCHS: I think
it's a struggle.
I think that it's a mind shift
that we work through every day.
Because there is
certain pressure
to maintain certain
KPIs to hit our goals.
But what we have
done has worked.
And the more we continue to
prove that this works, the more
leeway we're going to
have to able to say,
back off, this is
how we're doing it.
CHRIS MCGILL: I think we have
a luxury that other people may
not have when you go do this.
Because this does work.
It does maximize the
yield under the curve.
Like, I'm super convinced of it.
The great thing about--
for us is that we have--
"Fashion" has a five-year
track record of doing this.
They're going to have their
record year in the fifth year,
I don't know of
another game that
had their record year in
their fifth year, you know?
So mostly, when we
get pressure, we
can just sort of point at
our track record and say,
this is what we're doing.
I'm not going to say
that works every time.
EMILY PUTZE: Sure.
How closely do you
guys work together
even though you're
on separate games?
Like, how closely do
"Covet" and "Design Home"
work together, learn from each
other, lend each other money?
SARAH FUCHS: I'll start,
and you fin-- oh, we
lend each other money.
You know, I've only been with
Crowdstar for almost a year.
And I look to Chris and
the "Design Home" team
for advice and
feedback all the time.
I think that "Covet's"
a five-year-old product.
So "Design Home"
was really built
on the back of what
"Covet" was and took
a lot of great
learnings from it.
But the teams work
together all the time.
We have the "Design
Home" content team
and the "Covet" content
team working together,
learning from each other.
So I think we really rely
heavily on each other.
We have Judy out there,
who's our director of product
management, who works
for "Design Home,"
but who I talk to
all the time, and who
offers amazing,
relevant, helpful advice.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yeah, and
the truth is I actually
started on "Covet Fashion."
I ran BD in "Covet Fashion."
I hadn't been in games.
It was like drinking
through a fire hose,
definitely changed the
way I looked at the world.
But you know, "Fashion"
is our mother.
We are built on her shoulders.
You know, she fed us while
we developed the game.
We took everything
that we liked about it,
and we obviously
took our own take.
We have a different
kind of economy.
But the two games are
totally intertwined.
And we like each.
We like having brown
bag lunches and talking
about what's working,
what's not working, and why,
and lending resources
when we need to.
SARAH FUCHS: I think that's
one important thing about this.
I've been working in
games for 19 years.
And Crowdstar is one of
the first places I've ever
truly felt completely
supported, like with
an absolute family-like
environment where you can say,
hey, this is what I want to
do, and you're not running it
up the chain 150 times.
You're actually just
like, OK, we trust you.
We believe you.
Go for it.
But the Crowdstar
feeling is very familial.
We really support each other.
We really care about each other.
And you know, I'm all about
"Design Home's" success.
CHRIS MCGILL: It's not like we
don't have family squabbles.
SARAH FUCHS: Oh, we do,
no question about that.
But I think it speaks
to what the game is
when you have a
team that's really
supportive of each other.
EMILY PUTZE: Yeah, I
think that's right.
And you have different
experience sets too.
I mean, Sarah, I am interested
in learning a little bit more--
because of your
background in gaming,
you've mentioned that you
had to have this big mind
shift when you came to "Covet."
One of the first times I
met Chris, I said you know,
it would be so great--
because I'm obviously
coming from a
gaming perspective--
if there were timers, or
there was some gotcha,
or add this and this.
And he said--
CHRIS MCGILL: Over my dead body.
EMILY PUTZE: --no, no,
no, no, that's not for us.
And so how drastic was
that mind shift for you
coming from the gaming world?
SARAH FUCHS: Extremely drastic.
I mean, gotcha, and timers,
and things like that work.
They make money.
They make revenue.
And I come from mobile gaming
when it was in its infancy.
And those are the
things that work.
But we have a different
kind of audience.
We have a different
kind of game.
We're really toeing the
line between game and app.
And it's important for us--
and it was a shock for me.
It was like, OK, I
have to unlearn this.
I came in bubbling
with all these ideas.
And Chris and I--
in one of our first
meetings, I was like, Chris,
we could do this,
and this, and this.
And he was like,
slow down there.
Hang on.
Your ideas are great.
And we're not
going to do gotcha.
But I think it's
something that--
it's not the only way.
I think that there
are a lot of ways
to have a successful product.
CHRIS MCGILL: It actually
speaks to a lot of our qual, OK?
So we have quant
coming out of our ears.
And we have--
Judy's sitting right there.
Judy is the smartest person
on the planet, right?
And we are definitely
run by our data.
There's no question about it.
But what our qual said
is, what women love,
what our users love
about us, is that--
we actually divide them into
four different-- actually
in your case, six-- six
different player types
and what's important to them.
And you know what's
important to all of them?
No stress, relaxation,
creativity, inspiration.
So everything we do--
like when we say, OK,
we can make a million
dollars this month--
OK, well does it add stress?
Is it inspiring?
Is it creative?
Because if it isn't,
it doesn't go.
It just doesn't go.
If it is, great, let's do it.
EMILY PUTZE: That's amazing.
That's really unusual to be able
to stick to your user values
like that.
And I--
CHRIS MCGILL: Well, but it's--
SARAH FUCHS: It's the
core of who we are.
CHRIS MCGILL: It's the business.
It works for the business.
It's not altruism, It's
really good business.
EMILY PUTZE: Yeah.
One question I
wanted to ask you,
because it's
something that I think
is interesting for the style
of games you guys make,
and because my colleague
Moonlit, I know,
talked about this earlier--
one of the things we're seeing
in the games industry right
now is an increase in
exploring subscriptions.
So is subscription something
that you guys have ever
thought about offering?
Or do you have opinions
about subscriptions
in mobile games in general?
SARAH FUCHS: So I can't
speak to the past, what
they've thought about before.
But we're definitely
thinking about subscriptions.
I think that there were
a lot of great talks
earlier this morning.
I think that we need to think
about them in a different way.
We definitely are--
in fact, I have
a meeting about this this week.
But we need to think about
how they work for "Covet
Fashion" and "Design Home."
Because what works
for one type of game
is not necessarily
going to work.
But I think subscriptions
has a ton of possibilities.
I think there are ways we
could explore it, maybe,
with in-real-life stuff
tied into our products.
So I don't know what
that looks like.
I think there's just
a great future for it.
CHRIS MCGILL: We were
just kibitzing over here
while Moonlit was talking.
We were like, OK,
maybe we need to think
about this in a different way.
And maybe there's something that
we, as a very different entity,
can bring to the table
that takes those elements
but also adds other
elements into it.
And it's frightening at
first, to think about it,
like ooh, I got a good business.
I don't want to cannibal it.
And you're like
don't screw it up.
Don't screw it up.
But we are a company
that takes chances.
And I think we might talk
about a unique take on it.
SARAH FUCHS: Nice use
of the word "kibitzing."
That was great.
EMILY PUTZE: OK, let's switch
gears and do lightning round,
because I think we have
a couple minutes left.
But I have some good questions
that I have stored here.
So lightning round-- ready?
I wish I could limit your
answers to, like, words--
like three words each--
to make it harder.
But let's not do that.
CHRIS MCGILL: Green.
SARAH FUCHS: Three words each
EMILY PUTZE: No, no, please.
SARAH FUCHS: Green.
CHRIS MCGILL: I said that first.
EMILY PUTZE: What year
will "Design Home"
have its first AR,
integration, if ever?
CHRIS MCGILL: Next year,
in selective settings.
EMILY PUTZE: OK.
How many games will
Crowdstar have live in 2021?
SARAH FUCHS: More than three.
EMILY PUTZE: What's one thing
you wish you knew a year ago
and subsequently
did differently?
CHRIS MCGILL: This one's easy.
I wish I'd put more energy and
more focus into recruiting.
Because we're growing
really quickly.
And it's really hard
sometimes, especially when
you're doing live ops, to
lay down the track right
before the train goes over it.
And if any Unity engineers
are in the crowd,
meet me at the bar.
SARAH FUCHS: Analysts too.
EMILY PUTZE: Analysts?
CHRIS MCGILL: Just
about anybody, actually.
EMILY PUTZE: Sarah,
what about you?
Same question-- so
what's one thing
you wish you knew a year ago
that you would do differently?
SARAH FUCHS: You
know, it's hard for me
to say-- to have a
different answer than that.
But I wish that we had done
our "Covet Fashion" personas
earlier.
So I wish that we had been
able to really deep dive
on who our players are
earlier than we did.
Because we're having
a record year.
It's incredible.
And I think if we knew
then what we know now,
we could have-- last year could
have been a record year too.
EMILY PUTZE: Awesome.
Name another game
developer that you admire.
SARAH FUCHS: Network.
CHRIS MCGILL: I admire, I think,
Playworks for their success
and Roblox for their innovation.
EMILY PUTZE: Have you
or anyone you know ever
bought furniture out
of "Design Home?"
SARAH FUCHS: Yes.
CHRIS MCGILL: Yes,
including my wife.
EMILY PUTZE: What about
clothes from "Covet?"
SARAH FUCHS: Yes,
including myself.
EMILY PUTZE: All right.
SARAH FUCHS: It's great
when you go into a store,
and you're like,
that's our brand.
And then you buy it.
EMILY PUTZE: That's true.
It's useful, learning,
part of the hook.
SARAH FUCHS: Exactly
EMILY PUTZE: OK,
parting advice--
Chris, if you could offer
other game developers
one piece of advice
when it comes
to how they approach new game
design, what would that be?
CHRIS MCGILL: I think it's
write a value proposition.
I think games universally
try to solve the value
proposition of I'm bored.
But if you can entertain
people and tie it intrinsically
to their life outside the
game, that's defensible.
That's totally different.
It's additive.
It may not be curing cancer.
It might not be Mother
Teresa's work, right?
But it is additive, it's not
what other people are doing,
and you're competing
on a different plane.
EMILY PUTZE: Sarah,
knowing what you know now,
for game developers
who are trying
to pursue more meaningful
engagement or more
sustainable
monetization strategies,
do you have any tactical advice?
SARAH FUCHS: Create a
relationship with your players,
people who actually
play the game.
Think about the emotions you
want them to have while they're
playing, and as Chris
said, the emotion
you want them to have when
they put the game down.
And have that be
your North Star.
And focus on that
relationship with the player.
CHRIS MCGILL: And
that can be measured.
I mean, it can be
measured qualitatively.
EMILY PUTZE: Well, awesome.
Thank you guys so much for
doing this with me today.
I hope everyone feels like
they learned something.
SARAH FUCHS: Thank you.
CHRIS MCGILL: I have
one more thing to say.
What I really like
about it is we're
doing something very different.
And it's clear to me,
Emily and Moonlit,
that you have gotten
what we've done.
You've been a champion for this.
And it's the best.
EMILY PUTZE: I think
it's important to show
that you can be different
and extremely successful.
And so thank you so much
for joining us today.
CHRIS MCGILL: Thank you.
SARAH FUCHS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]